are you a high performer because of your
habits or are you a high performer in
spite of your habits i mean in every
industry there are people that are so
riddled with natural talent that they
can get away with mediocre work habits
and still be at the top of their field
but they're not the best that they're
capable of becoming and that's the
yardstick that we want to make sure that
we're measuring everything with
alan stein jr welcome to the show oh
it's so great to be with you
how would you describe your background
to all of the stuff that you've done in
your history to bring you up to this
point
well i've really had two parts to a
professional career in the the first
half of that was as a basketball
performance coach
and for 15 years my number one objective
was to help elite level players improve
their athleticism and bulletproof their
bodies on the court and then five years
ago i made a very distinct pivot uh pun
very much intended over to the corporate
space as a keynote speaker and author
where i translate the lessons and the
strategies and the disciplines that i i
learned from the world's best basketball
players i show folks how to apply those
to their lives and their businesses who
were you working with back in the day
so my main area of expertise was at the
high school level and i'm a washington
dc resident and i was able to work at
two different high schools here that
have produced over a dozen players
currently in the nba uh the most notable
of which is kevin durant so i had a
chance to work with kevin durant when he
was 15 years old and got a peek behind
the curtain of what it takes to ascend
to the top of the mountain and be world
class at your craft
and that actually led to work with
jordan brand nike basketball usa
basketball and i got an opportunity to
work events for already established
players like lebron james kobe bryant
stephen curry chris paul and i got to
see the other side of the curtain of
what it takes to actually sustain high
performance and excellence once you've
already reached that mountaintop it's an
interesting discussion because a lot of
conversations that i used to have maybe
four or five years ago were about
getting from that zero to 50 stage it
was about
focusing on basic skill acquisition
habit building life hacks stuff like
that routines and increasingly now the
conversations i'm having seem to be more
about sustaining that performance over
time iterating avoiding burnout avoiding
stress understanding when it's time to
move to a slightly different angle
whether whether you should continue
doing the thing that you're doing how to
find mentors how to be a mentor um and
that seems to be a little bit more of a
rare conversation i think you know the
vast majority of people by definition
are trying to get to the middle 50 of
excellence in whatever field there's as
you begin to ascend up and up and up
there are fewer and fewer people trying
to do that so there's less of a market
to market that too
oh so well said yeah and it's it's an
interesting dichotomy because i still
very much consider myself on the climb
and i'm still you know
moving up that ramp if you will um but
now my focus has shifted as you just
said so insightfully uh not as worried
about optimal performance as i am
sustaining that for long periods of time
and a good portion of that which is
really at the crux of my work at present
is doing that with a sense of joy and a
sense of fulfillment and a sense of
meaning that it's it's not just about
high performance that's certainly
important but it's also loving what you
do and deriving fulfillment and meaning
from what you do and i find that that's
actually the key to being able to
sustain excellence for long periods of
time i mean it's it's simply
unsustainable if you're not enjoying the
journey do you think that high
performance is sometimes at odds with
joy and fulfillment and meaning
oh absolutely yeah especially when you
you know and i'll i'll keep using
basketball as a reference since that was
my playground for so long you know you
would hear kobe bryant use words like
obsessed you know he was obsessed with
excellence and and i know that every
single word in the english language has
a different emotional connotation you
know we all perceive words slightly
different and and you know kobe was
certainly someone that that was obsessed
with what he was doing
they use that as a word to describe me
and certainly don't want that to be a
word that uh describes my journey why
once again there's nothing wrong with
the word itself it's just the emotional
connotation for me and and for some
reason um it's hard for me personally
for the word obsessed and the word
fulfillment and joy to coexist
simultaneously
another word that's very popular in
vernacular especially here in the states
uh is grind you know you need to be on
that grind you need to constantly be
grinding that's another word that that
just doesn't resonate with me and once
again this is not about words being
right or wrong it's just a matter of fit
um i don't want obsessed or grind to to
be anything that describes how i live my
life or or how i perform my work i think
that
something very few people realize is
that the strategies that are used by the
absolute elite and the best in the world
they don't scale particularly well for
pretty much anybody else like they're
only good for those people that are
prepared to sacrifice their entire lives
to go and do that and those are the
people that quite rightly we look up to
as heroes you know you see michael
jordan's
almost tyranny in the last dance right
he seems like this complete sort of
tyrannical leader forcing players to do
other things like almost sort of talking
down to the other guys in an effort to
try and get aggression and motivate them
up he's motivated by aggression you know
there's very much a resentful mentality
that he's got going on there no one
would ever look at any of those things
and think yeah that's a that's a
psychologically well-rounded human being
but what it did was it was able to
facilitate a very specific type of
performance in a very narrow domain
tiger woods is another amazing example
of this right he has been able to hone
his skills into one very particular
domain i don't want tiger woods ability
in relationships i don't want tiger
woods like psychological profile when it
comes to this the um psychiatric drugs
that he's on or his obsession with
training that's meant that he's spent
half a decade out of the sport due to
injuries so
it's it's a and this is where the real
devil's in the details that
how can we take the things that the best
in the world do
in terms of principles but then filter
them through
the understanding that this isn't
everything to us this isn't we might
have a family on the side of this we
might be prepared to look after our
evening time football practice or
whatever it is that we want to do that's
alongside close to our calling in life
and unless you're prepared to commit
absolutely everything to be the very
very very best in the world and it's the
source of income that you've got and
it's what your entire family's prepared
to support you with all of those other
things
those strategies from the top
they can be used but they need to be
mediated i think very much
oh absolutely there's so much insight in
what you just shared there i love the
direction that this is going you know i
think one of the big distinctions is the
guys you just mentioned whether it's
kobe bryant michael jordan uh or tiger
woods
their sole focus was on being the best
and that's not my focus mine is being my
best and there's a difference between
the two um if your goal is to be number
one in the world in absolute world class
and best in craft then as you said you
you almost need a maniacal obsession and
and have to be willing to sacrifice
everything in your life
uh and those guys have done that um
whereas for me that's that's not my
north star you know having some
semblance of harmony and balance being
my best and and please know i mean i
work incredibly hard at my craft i pour
everything into my speaking engagements
and my books but but i'm not comparing
myself to anyone else my goal is to do
the best that i'm capable of and one
other distinction that i've noticed and
this has been something i've used to
help guide myself
those guys were heavily attached to
achievement and to outcomes it was you
know i i win an nba championship or bust
there was no gray area if i win an nba
championship this season was a success
if we don't win an nba championship this
season was a failure it was incredibly
black and white um whereas as i choose
to look through a lens now of being much
more process oriented you know i
certainly would prefer to hit certain
outcomes and have certain achievements
but my
uh sense of of self my
confidence is not derived from those
i've learned to detach from those
outcomes and learn to simply love the
work love the steps love the process and
and i feel like if i can enjoy the work
then i've already won in advance and and
to me um that's taken a process of
unlearning and reconditioning myself
because i was incredibly outcome driven
and very achievement driven
for the vast majority of my life but
what i found was it put me on a roller
coaster of when i achieved then i felt
good about myself when i fell short i
didn't feel good about myself and that
was a very rocky road to be on because
i'm a huge believer that you should set
your goals and aspirations so high that
you're stretching that maybe you're only
hitting them at a 50 clip um you know if
you're achieving every goal you set i
think we can make a compelling argument
you're not shooting high enough um so
with that being said that meant half the
time i felt good about myself the other
half the time i felt lousy about myself
and and i just think life is too short
to spend half of your time feeling lousy
well the thing as well is that you'll
remember the failures and forget the
successes so even if you win 50 of the
time you'll focus on the losses 80 of
the time or 90 of the time that
negativity bias is awful the other thing
as well is that
other people's heads or external
achievements are a very fragile place to
pay to position your sense of self-worth
because you're constantly
you're not doing a thing in the hopes
that you've done it well you're always
looking at the reflection of what your
things achieved to see whether or not
it's worthy and yeah i mean take me
through that process of unlearning
because this is a process that i went
through throughout my 20s i ran a lot of
nightclubs if the club nights were
successful and busy then that meant that
i was good that week and if they weren't
very good then that meant that i was
poor that week and it was a very similar
process for me what did unlearning look
like to you well and let me go on record
saying that this is not coming from a
place of mastery this is still something
that that i occasionally struggle with
still something i find challenging you
know i'll occasionally find myself going
down that previous path but what i have
now at present is a heightened sense of
awareness and i usually catch myself
pretty quickly when i start playing the
comparison game or i start getting too
wrapped up in external measures of
validation or or any sense of
achievement and i usually catch myself
pretty quickly now and then kind of
tongue-in-cheek get myself back on the
the right path but ultimately it was
taking a step back and examining this
and i'm saying this in air quotes the
game that we've all been told that we
have to play and the the reality is we
don't have to play that you know we
don't have to derive our self-worth from
external validation and achievement you
know many people choose to do that and
that's fine because i think everyone's
on their own path and and i say that
with no judgment whatsoever had nothing
but compassion for everyone else but it
just wasn't the right fit for me so i
had to slowly keep reminding myself that
there's nothing wrong with desiring or
preferring certain outcomes but i can't
be attached to them and they certainly
can't be the sole source of my
self-belief in my confidence and my
self-worth and this untethering process
has been going on for the last few years
but i have to remember i spent you know
well over 40 years building that muscle
playing that previous game so i have to
give myself some patience and some grace
knowing it's going to take some time to
unlearn and recondition um but i don't
see any reason why i'm not going to be
on this planet for another 50 or 60
years so it's well worth the investment
i'm putting in now
talk to me about the common traits or
the common threads that you've seen
working with some of the most elite
basketball players on the planet what
are the most uh common themes that
you've noticed between them all
well the two that i've noticed the most
and i covered this in my first book
raise your game the first was high
performers never get bored with the
basics they embrace the fundamentals
they understand that the fundamentals
build the foundation to which the rest
of the house is built so in the game of
basketball it's obvious your
fundamentals include your footwork and
your shooting mechanics how well you
handle the ball and so forth so they
work on those basic skill sets
relentlessly
every single day um you know for the
rest of us that are not playing in the
nba we just need to figure out what are
the the basics or the fundamentals that
we need to commit to during the unseen
hours to work towards mastery of in any
specific domain of our life you know
being a brilliant podcast host like you
are you have to ask yourself what are
the handful of fundamentals that go in
to putting out a world-class podcast and
how can i continue to sharpen the sword
in those different areas so so never
getting bored with the basics is one
common theme and the second is they do a
brilliant job of blending well-earned
confidence with humility so they've
earned confidence on the court uh by
putting in the work during the unseen
hours you know taking hundreds of
thousands of shots in empty gems when no
one's watching uh gives them the right
to be confident when the whole world is
watching but at the same time they brush
that with a humility that leaves them
open to feedback leaves them open to be
coached leaves them open that no matter
how good they are even at the kobe
bryant or kevin durant level they know
they can still get better and they
welcome anyone that can help them do
that and
i find that that toeing that line
between confidence and humility and
staying open um is was another one of
the main themes of of high performers
talking about stresses how should people
think about managing the stresses that
they face
well the first is and this sometimes
comes across as a rather controversial
statement but but stress is a choice uh
stress is a choice because stress is not
actually derived from the circumstances
or the events in our life but it's
derived from our perception or our
perspective
of those events in those circumstances
so
if you can start to look through the
world through a rather neutral lens and
just say that this thing that happened
yes it might not be my preference might
not be to my liking but there's nothing
inherently stressful about what just
happened it's the emotion that i choose
to attach to it that will either
increase or decrease my stress and i
find that mindset incredibly liberating
because it gives you the power it gives
you the keys to the car ultimately it
says and this is again something that
i'm i'm working with and still
struggling with is being able to say
that it doesn't matter what happens in
the outer world
i'm gonna dictate my life through the
inner world so circumstances events what
people say what people do is not going
to dictate my mindset my perspective and
my attitude that's going to come from
within and and of course that's really
put to the test when really challenging
things happen so i i by no means ever
want to make any of this stuff sound
like it's easy you know everything i've
shared with you so far and everything i
will share for the remainder of our
conversation are very very basic
principles
but none of this stuff is easy there is
nothing easy about not letting the outer
world and what goes on you know
infiltrate your inner world and cause
you to increase stress so the very first
step is just learning to have an
acceptance of what you control and what
you don't and i find peace in the
acceptance of
it's not the universe's you know job to
do whatever it is that i want the the
world's just gonna do what the world
does it's my job to respond to that in a
way that moves me forward and takes me
closer to my north star and being the
best version of myself and i i find that
very liberating and empowering were any
of your players during your coaching
career dealt dealing with a a
particularly bad period of stress or
were there any stressful situations with
championships and titles and stuff like
that
oh absolutely i mean almost on a daily
basis i mean you know there are several
professions that i think we could all
collectively agree uh tend to be of high
stress and certainly being a
professional athlete is one of them
especially in today's day and age where
you are literally living in a fishbowl
and every single thing you do is going
to be heavily scrutinized and criticized
by everyone not just the the talking
suits on espn by everyone with a twitter
account is going to comment you know on
the fact that you had a poor shooting
night or or that your team lost you know
because you you turned the ball over in
the last possession so i think it's
incredibly
challenging and difficult but that's why
those guys understood how important
their mindset and their approach was and
almost all of them worked with some type
of sports psychologist that would help
them continue to build these skills
because they understood that that things
like mindfulness you know are a skill
set that need to be practiced just like
free throws you know they that's one of
the advantages of being a professional
athlete is they understand the power of
repetition they understand the power of
purposeful practice they understand the
the power of getting feedback and
constantly trying to tinker and and
tweak what you're doing so those guys
actually get it what about the stress of
pressure to perform or of criticism
that's something that even if it's not
on the scale of an nba superstar
everybody has in one form or another
quarterly reviews at work their current
business growth their relationship with
their partner
what did you learn from basketball
players about dealing with pressure to
perform and criticism from others
what's very in line with what we've been
speaking about it's it's taking
your eye off of the result or the
outcome and putting it on the process so
once again using a basketball analogy
a basketball player i know this this
might sound crazy they don't have a
hundred percent control over whether or
not the ball goes in the basket if they
did they would never miss a shot i mean
what player would ever not want to make
the shot but but all a basketball player
can control is is how they approach that
shot their footwork are they on balance
are they shooting with correct form are
they in rhythm is it the appropriate
shot to take time and score wise uh
where is the defender there's all of
these different things that that they
need to have this really quick mental
checklist to do and the great shooters
will tell you that the vast majority of
time when they can check off each of
those boxes there is a much greater
chance that the ball goes in the basket
so they have a heavy influence over
whether it goes in but the influence
comes from the process and it's the same
thing with all of us you know if you
work for an organization or a business
or a team your goal should be within
your role to show up as the best version
of yourself and do everything in your
power to make a meaningful contribution
to those around you
that's the part you have control over
now you can break that down further and
say well what are the things that i need
to do to show up as my best self well
part of that is physical i need to make
sure i'm well rested and get sleep i
need to make sure that i work out
consistently i need to make sure that i
eat healthy foods part of that is mental
you know i need to make sure that i'm
feeding my mind uh with the same
discernment that i feed my body so there
there's a list of steps that you can do
to increase the chance that on any given
day you will show up as your best self
and then once you know your role embrace
your role in star in your role then you
use that to make a meaningful
contribution to your team to empower
your colleagues and your co-workers and
better serve your clients and your
customers so that's the part that you
have influence over and when you put
your focus on doing those things it's
been my experience not only will you
perform at a higher level but you'll
also have more fulfillment from doing it
and then you just have to realize if i'm
doing those two things to the best of my
ability
i don't have any control over what my
quarterly evaluation evaluation's gonna
be or my year-end evaluation or or
whatever others think of me that part's
outside of my control and i just have to
be okay with whatever those things are
and doesn't mean you'll prefer them um
but it just means that you're gonna be
okay with them i wonder how much of the
disgruntledness that people have around
their performance or lack thereof comes
from the fact that they realize that
they were culpable in causing that to
happen but the fact that they know
that they left a lot on the table and
that deep down
there may be to blame for the fact that
the performance hasn't come the way that
it did i have a friend david perrell who
wrote an article called think like an
athlete has absolutely nothing to do
with this but the title set me off on
this this understanding that almost
nobody treats their chosen pursuit in
life with the same level of rigor that
athletes do except maybe sort of
professional classical musicians people
on the come up in in music and stuff
like that maybe but my point is that you
know when you're looking an athlete
their recovery their mindset training
their sleep their nutrition their game
day planning the people they spend their
time around their drills for technique
their sports and
conditioning their strength and
conditioning work everything that they
do
is built toward trying to maximize their
ability on game day and almost no one
else treats their chosen pursuit with
that same level of rigor because there's
so many degrees of freedom in between
your preparation and your performance
that you can always just let it go
everyone's rocked up
not prepared at all to some sort of
presentation or meeting or discussion
about whatever and nailed it and gone
[ __ ] hell i can't believe that i did
that you go okay like that just because
you were managed you were able to fluke
this performance
doesn't mean that that's a replicable
strategy that you should continue to go
forward with but the same thing goes for
let's say that you did you decided to go
out last night and stayed up until two
in the morning and had a few too many
beers and then you rolled in today and
everything seemed to be okay but you
still may be able to do okay but you're
not going to be able to draw the line
perfectly from poor sleep last night or
that pizza that you had a couple of days
ago or the fact that you haven't read
anything new in three weeks and you've
just been binge watching stuff on
netflix the line between performance and
preparation is so messy and blurry in
pretty much everything outside of sport
because the parameters are too
too uh fuzzy
that nobody is particularly concerned
about chasing things down in that way
and i just thought i i thought it was
interesting to apply that same level of
rigor to stuff uh and i also believe
that it will help people to feel more
bulletproof in their confidence and less
regretful because they go look i did i
did all of the things i did all of the
things that i was supposed to do and it
didn't come off so
there it is there's no more that i can
do
oh man there's so much gold in what you
just shared there and there's there's
two things that pop into mind uh the
first is kind of what we were talking
about earlier is this comparison game
with external validation this is someone
saying that yeah i was good enough
because i'm comparing myself to external
metrics
but the real you know test is are you
the best that you're capable of being
and that takes a very high level of
extreme ownership so so someone
shouldn't you know
feel fulfilled by doing less than their
best even though that was just good
enough
one of the questions that i asked during
my keynotes in my workshops are when i'm
working with high performers is are you
a high performer because of your habits
or are you a high performer in spite of
your habits i mean in every industry
there are people that are so riddled
with natural talent that they can get
away with mediocre work habits and still
be at the top of their field but they're
not the best that they're capable of
becoming and that's the yardstick that
that we want to make sure that that
we're measuring everything with and and
that does that takes incredible uh
ownership um extreme ownership jaco
willing wrote an entire book on it which
i'm a huge fan of and that is always
looking at yourself first you know that
is not falling to the tendency of
blaming complaining and making excuses
and deferring accountability and
responsibility to others it's holding
yourself fully accountable and i love
this idea of of treating yourself like
an athlete that is how i approach
everything that i do you know i know
that it's my job to get on stage and be
at my best to be in service of the
audience i also know that if i stay out
till two in the morning the night before
if i have several drinks if i eat a
bunch of really unhealthy food if i
decide to sleep in if i do those things
incrementally they give me less of a
chance to be my best which means now i'm
cheating the audience and
i have too much reverence and respect
for the groups i speak with and the
clients i have that i won't let that
happen so there is a time and a place to
do some of those things i'm not saying
you have to live a completely sterile
life
um but if you're very serious about your
craft and very serious about showing up
as your best self then you will have a
checklist a system a process for doing
just that and and you won't worry about
the external validation or measures of
achievement you'll know that you did
everything to be your best and to me
that's what puts you on the path to real
fulfillment
how do elite performers think about
managing their time and energy
well they one they understand that time
is finite and when it's gone it's gone
and we can't get any more of it so they
understand how precious it is but at the
same time they understand that that
energy is something that we can
replenish and we can rejuvenate and
that's why they take time off to
recharge their internal battery that is
why they do things like eat well and get
sleep uh so that they can have the
requisite energy so energy something
based on our lifestyles and the habits
that we have we can constantly replenish
i mean i can tell you as sure as i'm i'm
sitting here right now with you at 46
years old i have every bit as much
energy as i've ever had at any point in
my life uh statistically speaking energy
levels usually start to decrease as we
get older you know we're usually most
vibrant and alive in our teens and 20s
and it slowly starts to go downhill well
i don't want that to be the case in my
life so i i go you know the extra mile
in all of these different measures to
make sure that i can maintain an
incredibly high level of energy but but
time and energy uh are the two variables
that that we need to play with on a
regular basis and you know another area
that i've worked to make improvement in
is i'm a self-diagnosed people pleaser i
love saying yes i love saying yes to
things i probably shouldn't even say yes
to because it makes me feel good to be
of service to others
but but i learned that when you say yes
to one
thing
you are by default saying no to
something else and you need to get
crystal clear on what you're saying yes
to and then by default what you're
saying no to you know both you and i
have agreed to say yes to spend this
time together for this recording which
means during this hour we're recording
we are saying no to everything else that
could potentially happen and we have to
be okay with that trade and now i'm at a
point in my life where i have much
better discernment and feel much better
about what i say yes to and what i try
to say yes to now are only things that
are in perfect alignment with my north
star with my core values with the things
that interest and fascinate me and then
i respectfully and politely decline and
say no to things that that aren't in
alignment with that and and you know i
that's the other part that took some
reconditioning is making sure that i can
say no with some graciousness and some
tact and manners you know so it's not
about being harsh or rude to anybody
else it's just simply guarding your yard
and protecting your time so that you can
work towards being your best self and um
i'm better at that now still got some
work to do but i'm better than i was
several years ago for sure
what was that story about the college
basketball team where the coach had
worked out that if if they won on four
metrics 97 of the time they were going
to win the game what was that story oh
so
he actually just took another job but he
was bart lundy was the coach at queen's
university down in charlotte north
carolina which is one of the top two
division top division ii men's
basketball programs in the united states
and coach lundy is one of the best
coaches i've ever been around and he
figured out that there were four key
stats four key analytics that would
heavily determine whether or not queen's
university would win a basketball game
now
for one other distinction and and simon
sinek does a brilliant job covering this
in his book the infinite game but
basketball is a finite game uh around
the globe we've all unanimously agreed
that the team with the most points on
the scoreboard when the final buzzer
goes off is the winner we all agree to
that uh life and business is much more
evergreen there's not a distinct start
and stop um and we all haven't
unanimously agreed on what winning looks
like in life or business you know you've
had some amazing guests on your show uh
brilliant minds and i'm i'm sure that if
you asked each and every one of them to
define what winning looks like in life
and what winning looks like in business
yes you would see some overlap but you
would also see some things that were
different so the point is that's an
infinite game it's not unanimous however
there are some threads that we can pull
from that
and certainly apply but back to coach
lundy he figured out that when queen's
university comes out on top in these
four statistical categories the first
was turnover differential so if we can
have more possessions than our opponent
it gives us a better chance to win the
second was offensive rebound
differential if we can take more shots
than our opponent it gives us a better
chance to win the third were free throws
attempted which in college basketball is
the highest percentage shot per
possession if we can take more free
throws than our opponent it gives us a
better chance to win and the fourth were
three pointers attempted a massive
weapon in the college game and if we can
take more open looks from three than our
opponent it gives us a better chance to
win and coach lundy as you said just
perfectly pointed out when queen's
university comes out on top in those
four categories they win 97 of their
games which means they are statistically
almost unbeatable when they do those
four things now the lesson to pull from
that is
what do you think coach lundy and his
staff talk about
emphasize and remind
every workout every practice every film
session and before every game it's just
those four things he doesn't talk about
winning he doesn't talk about
championships he doesn't talk about
banners because he knows if they can do
those four things the the winning the
championships and the banners will just
take care of themselves you know it's
it's the old adage the scoreboard will
take care of itself so he puts all of
his focus on the process and designs
every practice workout and film session
around those four variables so that his
team will be prepared to execute and the
lesson the rest of us can pull from that
is we need to get crystal clear on what
winning and you can use a different word
if you don't like the word winning but
what does winning look like in your
business or what does winning look like
in your marriage what does winning look
like in your life get crystal clear on
that and then figure out what are the
the steps or the measurable analytics
that will increase the chance that i
will win in that domain and then just
focus on those things so you don't have
to you know sit up at night with a cold
sweat worrying about your marriage all
you have to do is figure out the three
or four things that go into a healthy
marriage and do those things as
consistently as you can and your
marriage will be just fine
well the problem is that we're finite
creatures surrounded by infinite
complexity right there are an
unbelievable number of ways that i could
try and contribute to having a better
marriage to
making more money to improving my
business or whatever it might be and
you're right refining down the metrics
of success that you're bothered about to
the ones that serve you that grow out of
your values that are aligned with your
integrity and so on and so forth i think
that that's important and i think that
the sense of overwhelm that also
contributes to stress
is
often born out of a lack of clarity
around what it is that you're trying to
achieve
uh what the contributing factors are to
that a lot of the time people say that
they want success and you go okay what
does success mean to you and you go i
don't know or
what's the route towards success or i'm
not too sure
okay well i mean if the thing that you
want in life is indefinable by the
person that's saying that it's the most
important thing to them
you're the blockage right you're the
you're the problem to yourself here
another word that you use which i
haven't heard very much is poise what do
you mean when you talk about poise
well first of all i love the fact that
you bring up clarity you know clarity
and i think a cousin of clarity is is
awareness especially self-awareness and
those things are are non-negotiables
when it comes to being on the path to
both high performance and fulfillment
you know you'll never improve something
you're oblivious to you'll never fix
something you're unaware of and it's the
same thing you're never gonna just
arbitrarily reach a goal that's that's
ambiguous and unclear so the more clear
you can get on what it is that you're
pursuing uh the better off you'll be so
i i really i'm really glad that that you
made that point uh poise ultimately
is the inner calm that that you exude
amidst all of the chaos you know it's
it's it's kind of a combination of
several of the things that we've been
talking about you know uh wayne dyer is
a little bit before my time but with
somebody that i actually really studied
and listened to and read a lot of his
work and during one of his uh
presentations um he picked up an orange
and he asked the audience he said if i
squeeze this orange what comes out and
the audience was kind of dumbfounded
they didn't even really know how to
answer it so he he basically you know
led them down the path and said well
will apple juice come out you know will
grape juice come out and then they
started laughing and he said no orange
juice will come out why will orange
juice come out and everyone said well
because that's what's inside and his
point was yeah when you squeeze an
orange what's inside will come out when
you get squeezed with with adversity or
challenge what's inside of you what's
going to come out and that's really the
epicenter of poise it's it's the ability
to maintain that inner calm stay aligned
with your core values um understanding
the concept of standards over feelings
you know knowing that emotions are going
to ebb and flow but your your standards
of excellence and your principles and
your non-negotiables those should never
waver and and the real test of that
is actually during uh adversity and you
know one of the the extensions of that
that i love
a good friend of mine who's the mental
performance coach for the san francisco
giants in major league baseball says our
emotions are designed to inform us not
direct us
and i love that because to me that that
coincides with poise that that it's okay
that if you're feeling angry or upset or
dejected or frustrated but you can't let
those feelings dictate your behavior or
dictate how you treat others you know
you can't let those feelings rattle you
uh when the stakes are high and and
really that's that's poise is not
letting the emotions in the moment
overtake
your true essence
you see this when people get put under
pressure if you've ever been locked in a
lift with someone or stuck in traffic
waiting to get somewhere that's when
someone's true nature comes out you
don't need to be in a war zone with
somebody injured on the ground and
you've got to is he going to drag it out
it's like no no just get stuck in
traffic when you're late for an
important meeting like that someone's
pure nature comes out there one of the
things that we do a lot with club events
is we need to manage queues outside of
very busy venues so it's let's say it's
halloween and we've got 2 000 kids
trying to get into an event that we're
running and the coordination problem
between all of the different queues
there's this one for tickets and there's
this one for guest list and there's this
one for tables and vip and the door
staff is shouting at you and all of the
door staff are mid-40s
full of testosterone gorillas from the
northeast of the uk and they just they
don't care about making the event an
enjoyable experience they just want to
have as little stress as possible and we
have these lads that come and work for
us and girls as well
that are you know 18 19 20 years old
they were
children a couple of years ago and then
they get brought into a business they're
operating a business and then after a
little bit of training we throw them out
onto the to this sort of lion's den of
look there are 2 000 people waiting
outside of this venue you've learned the
skills of how you need to coordinate
this stuff and one of the coolest things
that we see is
some young guy or girl that's arrived at
uni a couple of years ago and is like a
a beautiful conductor just holding off
the door staff the door staff's like
shouting and screaming get these [ __ ]
people into the queue right now he's
like just give me one second i'm just
going to go and sort it over there won't
just hold on there mate it'll be i'm
going to go get it okay right
and you just see these and they just own
it and it is that pure sort of presence
in the midst of what is very sort of
tangible chaos now it's not super
emotional but it's very visceral right
like it's there it's a cute it's in your
face as soon as it's finished they're
gonna forget about it but um it's really
cool to see that and and being able to
watch the skill acquisition of young
guys and girls to become
so present and have so much poise during
that stressful situation it's pretty
cool it's one of the coolest things we
do oh man that is so neat i i
admittedly wish i would have had that
level of poise when i was 18 or 19 years
old because i most certainly didn't this
is another one of the rather newfound
traits that i've been very cognizant of
to work on but boy what those folks you
just described they're setting
themselves up
for a much smoother life down the line
because they understand that they are in
control of their response you know going
back to something we talked about
earlier
whether they're doing it consciously or
unconsciously is irrelevant they
recognize that the chaos and the madness
of two thousand people possibly many of
which are disgruntled is outside of
their control
they have nothing to do with that what
they can do is control their poise and
their response to those folks and it
sounds like from what you described they
choose to pick a they choose a response
that helps move them forward helps
improve the situation and certainly adds
a level of comfort and service to those
they're working with and that's
beautiful what they understand as well
is that the more calm that they are the
more calm the situation gets so it's
almost as the tension of a of the night
outside gets more you see the guys even
lean in today they're sort of um
they'll speak more quietly to the door
staff they'll go over and speak to them
really really close as opposed to having
to shout across the queue it's really
really smart it's really cool what they
do um
but yeah and you're right as well that
you know 18 19 20 years old these kids
go on it's one of the lads that's just
picked up an unbelievable
job trading in out in singapore uh and
you know some high pressure trading desk
and i have absolutely no concerns at all
for him he's going to walk in there and
be one of the most competent people when
it comes to a high pressure environment
because
who else in here has managed
50 or 100 or 150 club nights with
hundreds and hundreds of teenagers
screaming at you because they want to
get into this venue none of them so yeah
it's um
those sorts of experiences i think are
very formative and uh it's the sort of
thing i feel like everybody should uh
have to manage the exterior of a club
night at one point in their life just so
that they get to learn some of the
lessons from it but you talk as well in
the book about how stress can enhance
performance
one of the problems that you have is
that straight the response to stress can
often be for us to freeze for our
thinking to become more narrowed is it
simply
an experience game is it just getting
repetitions in or is there something
else that people can do to try and
expedite that improvement curve well a
good portion of it is simply uh
repetition and life experience which is
why generally speaking once you have an
awareness of this and i'll use myself
speaking in the first person i mean i'm
i'm much better at managing stress now
at 46 than i was at 36 or 26 because i
can only imagine how many reps i've
gotten in
over the last one or one or two decades
and you know we we said something
earlier that i want to circle back to
and that's this concept of unlearning
and also tying that in with what we
talked about from an extreme ownership
standpoint i just want to make sure that
folks know that your response to
situations is in your control many
people have
had the same knee-jerk visceral reaction
to certain things of stress and you
mentioned a major trigger before which
is sitting in traffic that they they no
longer feel a sense of control they feel
that when they are stuck in traffic and
they are late for an appointment that
the only response they can have is one
of being irritated frustrated agitated
like they don't even believe that
there's another option and and i was
certainly one of those folks until i saw
the proverbial light and realized that
there is nothing inherently stressful
about cars in front of you on on the
freeway the stress is the emotion that
you choose to attach to those cars and
you know using you and i as an example i
can be stuck in traffic and i can white
knuckle the steering wheel and i can
honk my horn give somebody the finger
curse under my breath start to sweat
blood pressure goes up get frustrated
and then i look over and you can be as
cool as a cucumber sitting literally in
the car next to me and you can either be
embracing some quiet time or some
stillness or maybe you choose to call a
close friend and catch up or maybe you
choose to listen to an awesome podcast
like you put out and and use that as a
time for some professional development
but both of us are sitting in the exact
same external circumstance but we would
choose to view that very differently and
obviously in that hypothetical example
i'm inviting stress into my life and
choosing that to be a stressful
situation where you would be choosing
the other and i just want folks to know
that if at present you're kind of the
white knuckle honk the horn type person
you can unlearn that behavior and you
can go down a more peaceful path i'm
living proof of it i know for a fact it
can be done
what was that kevin durant strength
session story
oh so i i had a chance to meet kd uh
when he was 15 years old and there's
actually two stories about kd that i
always love to share both of which i
think speak volumes about him and uh the
first was it it took a lot of convincing
to get him to come in for a strength
workout you know i watched kevin play
and within the first couple minutes of
watching him it was really obvious that
this kid had unbelievable physical
talent potential he had a very high
basketball iq and he loved the game of
basketball but it was also very obvious
that he was
rather slight afraid he was a little bit
frail you know at the time i met him kd
was almost 6 10 uh and and less than 180
pounds which made he was very real thin
so it was obvious to me as a strength
and conditioning coach that one of the
only things that could limit his ability
to play at the highest level would be
lack of strength and power
but it did take some convincing for his
mom to let him come in for a workout he
had never done any type of formal
training before and when he came in i i
got a little bit too excited because man
i laid the hammer on him i absolutely
blasted him and he didn't say very much
during the workout and about 20 minutes
in he was literally laying on the gym
floor in the weight room uh dripping
with sweat muscles were shaking and and
since he didn't say much i wasn't sure
whether or not he liked the workout so i
just asked him point blank and i still
remember to this day it makes me smile
he said no i didn't like the workout but
i know this is what i need to do if i
ever want to play in the nba so when can
i see you again coach
and i remember being blown away at his
maturity and his perspective and his
mindset that he was willing to embrace
doing something that caused a tremendous
amount of physical mental and emotional
discomfort and anguish but he knew that
that was what would put him on the other
side of where he was trying to go and he
was willing to make that sacrifice and
uh we ended up enjoying a very great
good relationship for the next couple
years i was able to make some tweaks on
my end so he would actually enjoy the
workouts more but nevertheless he made a
commitment to doing something that he
didn't necessarily want to do in the
moment but he knew that he had to do to
get where he was trying to go and and i
think that that ability to lean into
sacrifice that ability to make
commitments to do things that we know
will lead to our growth and development
um as opposed to taking the easier fork
in the road uh is really really
important and one other quick kd story
and i don't tell this one near as often
um part of our our morning routine was
you know i would drive halfway around
the beltway here in dc about a 50-minute
drive to pick him up before school to
take him to the local ymca to get in a
workout beforehand so you know i'm up at
4 30 in the morning picking him up at 5
30 in the morning to get in a workout
before school and
most teenagers don't love or embrace the
super early morning hours at least
that's been my experience and we were
walking into this ymca one morning and
there was an elderly woman working the
front desk uh i didn't ask for her
driver's license but i'm guessing she
was 75 years old and we were both
walking in and kevin had a hood on and
he had his head down and she said good
morning guys
and he didn't say anything he just kept
walking
and then the lady said it again a little
bit more sternly this time she said good
morning guys
and i remember having this brief pause
thinking oh my gosh i don't know what's
about to happen you know kevin is a he's
a teenager you know so he's riddled with
all sorts of hormones and confusion he's
an absolute alpha male he's one of the
best basketball players in all of high
school basketball
what is he going to say to this lady and
i at this time i had only been working
with kevin for a few weeks so i didn't
get to know him well enough to know how
high his character was and he turned
around he took his hood down and he said
i'm sorry ma'am good morning
and i just remember in that moment
realizing okay this kid is is cut from a
very high moral fabric that he's he's a
good person he's high character you know
he he understood that he made a mistake
was a little bit impolite in the moment
and he decided to correct that you know
and and i knew at that point that he
would have the character to support
whatever greatness he was going to
achieve on the court and i certainly
didn't know at that time during either
one of those times that kevin would go
on to be you know one of the best
basketball players of of our generation
and and certainly one of the top scorers
in the history of the nba
i couldn't have predicted that by any
means but at the same time i'm not even
remotely surprised by it you know once i
saw his work ethic his commitment his
sacrifice and his character i'm not even
remotely surprised that he's as good as
he is
that's a dope story it's really cool to
find out about people that are that uh
humble and prepared to take on
their own failures you're right it is
kind of a little bit of a superpower one
of the other things that you've been
talking about a lot is stagnation where
do people start if they feel themselves
being a little bit stagnant
well it starts with your inputs you know
i'm a huge believer and i believe you
said something earlier that alluded to
this and i really loved the way that you
said it you know our inputs determine
our outputs the things we choose to read
watch and listen to the people we choose
to invest our time with
heavily influence the way we see the
world our philosophy our mindset and our
perspective so if you start to stagnate
and you want to start improving your
outputs then you need to start getting
better inputs you need to switch up what
you're reading watching and listening to
you know you mentioned something earlier
maybe you've kind of um lately created
the habit of just binge watching
something mindless on netflix instead of
listening to a podcast or maybe watching
a documentary or maybe reading a new
book so you just need to turn that dial
and you need to start improving your
inputs and same goes with the people you
invest your time with you know i i know
i don't remember who said it original
originally i think it was one of the
guys on the mount rushmore of of the
personal development space you know zig
ziglar and brian tracy and jim rohn but
one of them said something about you
know you are the equivalent of the five
people you spend the most time with and
you need to make sure that you're
constantly recalibrating that list and
constantly having high discernment with
the people that you are choosing to
spend time with and many times when you
stagnate it's because the people you're
spending time with have been stagnating
and the things you're reading watching
and listening to have been stagnating as
well and and you're the one that
controls being able to jump start either
one of those so that's that's definitely
taking control of those is a great first
step
i like the idea of changing environment
i can't remember who it was someone
asked on a q a a couple of months ago
they were at university or something and
they were feeling a little bit stagnant
even though you know you're going
through a university course you're
progressing right there is a there's an
upward trajectory to that it's like dude
just go and do a season abroad over your
summer you know
you're in the uk you can go to spain or
greece or somewhere and go and work as a
barmaid or a barman or something in some
local bar you're going to meet an entire
new group of people you're going to
develop it yourself into learning about
a new culture there's going to be
complete everything is going to change
and i'm aware that it's not doable for
everyone but i do think that a short
trip to go somewhere else abroad to just
eat some new food smell some new smells
meet some new people understand
different things about different
cultures
it changes your perspective and you're
right like it's such an obvious answer
when you think about it like what is
stagnation it's a lack of movement it's
a lack of new stimulus so how do you fix
that okay well just get some new
stimulus the
it's very difficult to
no matter how ingrained your habits are
for you to be picked up out of where you
are deposited somewhere completely new
with different people and different
everything else and you somehow be able
to completely recreate the existing life
that you tried to leave behind in a
completely new environment oh man so
much power behind that and yeah our our
environment dictates so much of this and
that's the first place you need to look
to shake things up
i know um part of it very in alignment
with what you just shared you know is
also stepping outside of your specific
vocation or industry uh so an example i
always use you know as a professional
keynote speaker i actually don't spend a
ton of time
studying other keynote speakers
i do that a portion of my professional
development but i actually spend a ton
of time uh studying two different uh art
forms based on spoken word one is
hip-hop and the other is stand-up comedy
those are two areas that that i try to
study religiously to learn new ways to
communicate more effectively through
spoken word uh to challenge me and my my
physicality or my my staging and my you
know boxing the the way that i uh
emphasize different points you know both
are usually genres that are brilliant at
telling stories and and i want to be a
really good storyteller when i'm on
stage so i try and study those things
outside of my specific domain and then
something else i do personally and this
is more from a physical fitness
standpoint is i always try and have
something on my calendar to be training
for you know i'm 46 years old i don't
play sports competitively anymore you
know i'm a weekend warrior so you know
it can get re it's easy to fall into
stagnation of just kind of going to the
gym three or four times a week following
a a mundane workout so for me i like to
have something six to eight to ten weeks
out that i'm training for specifically
well
uh a spartan race was something i did a
couple of months ago uh the next thing i
have on my calendar i'm actually doing a
it's a navy seal experience it's a 36
hour um
experience where you're you're kind of
put through the ringers a a civilian
version of what navy seals go through i
would never in a million years uh
believe that i'm going through what they
go through and then i actually have an
ultra marathon scheduled for the end of
the summer so for me i like the variety
of training for different things because
then i have to prepare differently i
will prepare differently for this navy
seal experience than i will for an ultra
marathon at the end of the summer and um
i like being able to shift those things
and and once again
i'm not saying that's going to work for
everybody but that's something that i've
used that i you know really embrace that
keeps me from getting stagnant just in
my physical fitness well yeah you've got
a consistent cycle externally that's
always sort of tumbling something
through the strange thing is that
taking control of a situation and
knowing that you can direct your life is
one of the first things that gets
forgotten during a stagnation period
you're very much sort of at the mercy of
whatever occurs in front of you you're
always very reactionary you're not
leaning into discomfort you're not
taking the first step uh and i had this
conversation with a guy who's just
written a great book on anxiety
yesterday
how
both of these things spiral down and
spiral up the same way when everything's
going well you begin to get more
resilient you lean into more discomfort
which gets you more positivity and more
confidence and more good feedback and
the reverse happens as well when you
feel like you're getting blasted around
by life and what i'm fascinated by
is the ability for people to step in and
pattern interrupt that downward spiral
like that for me is where so many people
get caught and obviously the sooner that
you can do that the easier it's going to
be the longer that you instantiate a
habit the harder it is to break that the
longer that you've had a mindset or a
routine you know there's people who are
in
three year long downward spirals where
they've kind of always just been at the
mercy of something and it's no longer
that this is a downward spiral this is
their nature this is who they are in
their inner essence because it's been
our memories are really really short you
know you do something you take up a new
sport you start doing crossfit for three
months you can't remember what it was
like to not do crossfit you are crossfit
right you and crossfit have become one
you've fused into this single being and
the same thing happens in both ways so i
think one of the important things that i
try to remember especially during
stagnation periods is look the quicker
that i can try and pat and interrupt
this the quicker that i can give myself
some new stimulus to make myself feel a
little bit excited to get myself
something that i can focus on to try and
be positive to get back into leaning in
into discomfort all of those things seem
to really benefit me and they always
seem to sort of get me back on that
upward spiral more quickly oh that's so
so true and you know as we were talking
about kind of extreme ownership and
always holding the mirror up to yourself
first at the same time i want to
recommend that folks insulate themselves
with people that can help you see some
blind spots and can help tell you when
you start to stagnate because one of the
the tricky parts about stagnation is
it's not as over dramatic as hitting
rock bottom you know most people when
they hit rock bottom uh that will
basically propel them into making some
type of massive life change but but
stagnation is just kind of this this
numb feeling it's this mental cruise
control it's it's just treading water
and and often i know it's been the case
in my life
i was one of the last to realize i was
stagnating it took other people in my
life that cared enough about me to tap
me on the shoulder and and try and push
me a little bit further you know get me
the stretch um and get me to break out
of that and turn the downward cycle and
spiral into an upward one so as much as
i believe in self-reliance and extreme
ownership i also don't want folks to
think that you need to go through life
in isolation and that it's all on your
own shoulders you know we we we are
communal creatures we need to surround
ourselves with people that can help us
see these blind spots and and that
starts with in a humility of an
acknowledgement that we all have blind
spots we can't see them hence the reason
they're called blind spots but other
people can from their vantage point and
they can bring a blind spot into our
consciousness or our awareness and and
for that we should we should welcome and
encourage that so i know there have been
a few times in the past decade that i've
put on the mental cruise control and hit
stagnation and each time i was kind of
the last to realize it it took someone
else to bring it to my attention and
because i welcomed their feedback and
appreciated them caring enough to tell
me then i was able to quickly
have the pattern interrupt love that
phrase and and reverse that that cycle
to move it upwards talking about hitting
rock bottom and stuff like that you say
that burnout is the long-term effect of
misalignment what do you mean
so many people think burnout just comes
from working long hours or making
sacrifices and that's not the case i
mean we talked about the very start of
this conversation somebody like kobe
bryant who has put in the hours and made
immense sacrifice unparalleled sacrifice
and he certainly wasn't burnt out on the
game of basketball i mean the man was at
the top of the mountain for close to 20
years
it comes from a misalignment when the
work you're putting in the hours you're
logging and the sacrifices you're making
are no longer in alignment with your
interests with your core values with
where you're fascinated with feeling
like you're making a meaningful
contribution so if you're just putting
in the work but you're not getting any
fulfillment from the work that's when
burnout's inevitable um because we all
know folks and and i'm sure you and i
are two of them that can love the work
that we're doing so much we don't mind
putting in long hours and making certain
sacrifices because it's in harmony with
where we're trying to go and who we're
trying to become and that's the most
important part so when someone starts to
experience burnout that's where they
need to look it's not just about cutting
back on hours it's making sure that the
hours you're putting in are meaningful
they're purposeful they're in alignment
with who you're trying to become they're
in alignment with your core values they
happen to be doing things that you're
fascinated by and interested in and you
know that was one of the reasons that i
left the basketball training space five
years ago was that was no longer filling
my bucket and lighting me up you know
helping players run faster and jump
higher i enjoyed that for 15 years but
it was no longer
as meaningful to me so i had to switch
to something where i was fascinated and
curious and i found more meaning and
that was why i shifted to keynote
speaking and writing so um we can avoid
burnout if we're willing to keep our
eyes up and open and pay attention to
those those two different domains
i do think as well with burnout no
matter how passionate you are no matter
how fulfilled you are about whatever
pursuit you're doing at the moment
tolerating how much you put your foot on
the accelerator is something that's
really important right because
you need to protect your passion and you
need to do that by making sure that the
thing that you love doesn't get turned
into a labor very easy to do this i see
friends do this a lot of the time so uh
a friend will have a huge interest in
fitness they've always loved going to
the gym they decide to become a pt they
decide to become an online coach then
they decide to coach online coaches
because coaching online coaches makes
more money than whatever they're still
in the fitness world but now they're
answering 200 emails a day they're
running a business with a sales team of
15 people they're trying to organize
this huge huge business they're still in
the fitness industry but they've
monetized their passion
so much that they've no longer protected
it they're miles away from doing the
thing that they actually used to love
which was fitness they don't do fitness
anymore they're four degrees removed
from the closest person that's actually
doing fitness and because they've
monetized it there's this sort of
consistent conveyor belt so that's
something i think as well that
you need to be very cautious with when
it comes to burnout there's not many
there's not a lot of things that you get
offered on a plate that is your passion
right here is a thing that the universe
has just delivered you that you've also
stumbled on that you're also able to do
and yet
you can destroy you can erode that
passion one
arduous day at a time right by forcing
yourself by turning it from a get to to
have to like you are just going to erode
your desire to do that thing so that's
something that i think when it comes to
burnout if you want to play that
infinite game if you want to be able to
think okay how do i sustain my
motivation and my enthusiasm for this
pursuit for the next 15 years
don't throw everything that you've got
at it right now know that you need to
take a break even if
it's going to mean a sacrifice of
revenue even if it's going to mean a
sacrifice in terms of growth of whatever
it is the project that you're doing
pull back off it a little bit i think
that's an important lesson that i don't
hear very much oh for sure in fact the
single best advice i ever got as a young
person was find what it is you love
find what it is you're naturally pretty
good at and then find where those two
things intersect and where those two
things intersect that is your strength
zone and the more time you can invest in
your strength zone the higher your
you'll perform and the more fulfilled
you'll be now keep in mind as we get
older we will develop new passions and
we will improve skill sets so that point
of intersection is not going to stay
static it's going to change um but but
yeah in the example you just gave which
was so insightful and so perfect
that person
started to move that point of
intersection unconsciously away from
what they loved and what they were good
at to the point that it was no longer um
you know even in the same ballpark
they're now basically managing other pts
and trainers and spending all of their
time on email when that's not what they
love and that's not what they're good at
so we have to take control of that and
and also to circle back to much earlier
in the conversation when you talked
about that book about you know running
our lives the way athletes do you know
athletes understand that that proper
rest and recovery uh is not a nice to
have it is a non-negotiable after a
really hard strength workout you have to
have a period of time where you let your
body recover and you get good sleep and
you eat healthy foods and then your body
will build itself back stronger you
can't go in the gym and lift the maximum
amount of weight every single day for
you'll burn yourself out and in this
case you'll injure yourself
when you look at professional athletes
like nba players they have a distinct
off season you know where they can
actually change the way they approach
life and training which is different
from the end season or the preseason so
it's important that we do the same thing
i love your analogy about putting the
foot on the gas you know you can't have
it on the gas at all times even elite
level indy car drivers or nascar drivers
don't have their foot on the gas the
entire time they have to be willing to
take their foot off the gas or hit the
brake a little bit when they're going
around turns or they're trying to
maneuver around someone and you know the
the other analogy that jumps out with
that foot on the gas concept is you know
regardless of someone's fitness level i
just want you to think how fast you're
capable of running a hundred meter dash
and then also think about how fast
you're capable of running a marathon two
distinctly different different uh
different distances
obviously you cannot run a marathon at
the same pace that you run the 100 meter
dash it's not sustainable so we have to
be willing to
to sprint intermittently when times need
it you know you might have a work
project or finishing a deadline for a
client or finishing up a book or a
manuscript where you have to put the
foot on the gas to drive through that
finish line but then you need to balance
that with times of rest and recovery and
then take more of the marathon approach
and learning how to toggle in and out of
those different you know mediums um is
how you'll you know
sustain performance and fulfillment
did you say you'd work with steph curry
i did yeah i i met steph curry back in
2007 i was working the kobe bryant
skills academy and steph was actually a
college counselor at the time and this
was the year before he blew up on the
national scene so this was a year before
anyone even knew who he was or anyone
had even heard of davidson that was the
first time i met him and i knew there
was something really impressive about
him then and then i had a chance to work
with him again when he decided to to
enter the nba draft uh the agent he
signed with was a dc area agent and
brought steph here for about eight weeks
leading up to the draft and i got a
chance to train him every day leading up
to that so um yeah it was a really
really cool experience and then i had a
chance to work chris paul's camp uh a
few years and steph would come because
him and chris are really good friends uh
so i got a chance to to be around him
then as well so he's one of my all-time
favorite people i don't know that you
could find a more humble superstar than
you can with steph curry what's he like
what's his what's unique about him
one he has an immense sense of gratitude
like he is incredibly appreciative of
the opportunities that he's been
afforded um he's a family man
he's you know incredibly gracious with
with his uh his brother and sister as
well as his parents as well as his wife
and children um he has an immense
respect for the game of basketball you
know he respects the players that came
before him and understand that they laid
a foundation that allows him to play
this game at a high level um but he's
always he's also incredibly confident i
mean you know for those of your
listeners that really follow the nba i
mean
steph curry has literally changed the
game i mean he has changed the way nba
defenses are played he's changed the way
teams utilize the the three-pointer you
know i mean in one season stephen curry
made more threes than larry bird made in
his entire career which just shows the
evolution of the game and and that's not
a detriment to larry bird he's one of
the best of all time but the
three-pointer was kind of an
afterthought in the 80s and early 90s
and now it's arguably the the number one
shot teams look for um and a good
portion of that is is because of of
steph and and his commitment to his
craft and i don't think the average
person understands
the time energy effort and focus that he
puts in during the unseen hours you know
if i don't know when this is gonna
actually air but if the nba playoffs are
still going on and the golden state
warriors are still alive and you happen
to turn on the game and at the end of it
you see steph had 60 points and made 12
three-pointers
most people would be so blown away by
that
but if they knew how much work he put in
in empty gems when no one else was
around
you'd be less surprised i mean it's
still an incredible feat but when you
know how many times that young man has
gone in the gym to to make shots and
he expects to go out and make 12 threes
he expects to go out and drop 60 points
because he's put in the work to earn the
right to be able to do that he doesn't
leave anything to chance doesn't leave
anything to happen stance or accident he
puts in the work to deserve that success
and one other thing that makes him
incredibly unique and is why he will go
down in history as the greatest shooter
the game has ever seen is his ability to
be in the present moment and and wipe
the slate clean it does not happen very
often because he's so good but steph
could miss the first seven shots he
takes in a game and he will shoot that
eighth shot with the same confidence as
if he had made the previous seven he
doesn't bring baggage from the past and
he doesn't let misses from the pass
affect the present he takes every single
shot as if it's its own shot and that
joker could miss 30 shots in a row and
with two seconds left in the game tied
he will still be begging for the ball
because he believes the next shot is
always going in and that is a really
really difficult mindset to master but
he's about as good as anyone i've ever
seen
alan stein jr ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out the stuff that
you do online why should they go
they can go to allensteinjunior.com i
also have a supplemental site stronger
team.com i'm very active on social media
on all the major platforms at allen
stein jr and if they're interested in
either one of my books you can search
for raise your game or sustain your game
on amazon or audible or wherever you get
books and i'd love to keep the
conversation going so if you like
something that we chatted about today
just shoot me a dm on instagram and
would love to keep this rolling allen i
appreciate you cheers man thank you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you